and to have to let him get what he wants
you know what he asked for
and what he needs right now which is his
family
even though if you know it's temporary
and it's
it's not forever it's a temporary
situation and
after all he's had to go through how how
could you deny him
that and because of what because uh
what some strangers might think or say
ryan dorsey is speaking out about those
rumors circulating about his
family and opening up about how he and
his son
josie have been doing since the death of
his ex-wife
naya rivera i have to tell him oh she's
an angel now and
she's with god and she's in heaven and
he says well
i want to go there how do i get there
i wouldn't wish that upon any of your
ears to have to hear that
hear those words come out of the
sweetest soul you know
the 37 year old was visibly emotional as
he shared that his life is not always
black and white
on instagram tuesday following recent
headlines about nya's younger sister
nikayla who moved in with him
and five-year-old josie he asked me if
tt can live with us
i want tt to live with us forever
because she's now the closest thing that
he has to a mom
because you're gonna need all the help
you can get
as a single parent trying to
build your career and navigate this
disaster with your child and
you deal with it every hour of every day
for
80 plus days now a source previously
told et that ryan and michaela decided
to move into a house together to raise
josie as a team
to have a young woman who was as blood
as tt who's willing to
put her life on hold and sacrifice
things
uproot her situation for the betterment
of your child
so when you put your child to bed you
don't always have to be alone with your
thoughts and
you don't have to be sad every day and
night wondering when does it get better
at least you have
someone there with you to
talk to or just sit in silence and
be sad with rumors have been circulating
that the two
are romantically involved but our source
says that's simply not true
quote anyone who knows them knows it's
completely absurd to imply that they are
anything more than just
family i wasn't even going to speak on
any of this but
i feel like my head is full of so many
things right now that uh
the last thing i want running through my
head is
dyspo et's source adds that the recent
scrutiny they're facing
really blindsided them and they barely
have the mental capacity to deal with it
i probably lost a little over 20 pounds
i don't get good sleep i'm sad every day
the source also says that nikayla has
been getting death threats in her dms
and people not just paparazzi have been
stalking them
and taking their pics i also hope if you
ever have to deal with anything tragic
that
you will have peace and never having um
people following you and take pictures
and and
creating a false narrative based on an
angle of a photo
two people grieving who have been living
their life out of suitcases
and you know just trying to get settled
into a new place
et source explains quote they're beyond
exhausted
these rumors and the resulting hatred
they've received is pushing them
over the edge but it's 2020
and uh this is life
it's 20 20 man we're here
on monday the 25 year old model
seemingly responded to the rumors on her
instagram story
writing in the darkest time of my life
the only thing that is important is my
friends and family
showing up for my nephew even though i
can't show up for myself
i'm not concerned with the way things
look because no one can see
each agonizing moment we all endure
you